that was one day left before the U.S
midterms a final campaign push is
underway seats in both chambers of
Congress are up for grabs as well as
governorships and City mayoral offices
President Joe Biden has been campaigning
in New York where the state's Democratic
governor Kathy hokel is facing a tight
race against her Republican rival former
president Donald Trump was calling on
crowds in Florida to support Republican
candidates in Tuesday's vote
[Music]
and more than 8 million Young Americans
are getting ready to vote in the
elections for the first time many will
be looking to elect lawmakers to bring
about change and experts are saying
they're less motivated by party and more
by policy
Jamie is a dedicated climate activist
she was sending campaign postcards to
people around the country before she was
old enough to vote
now in these midterm elections she
finally has a voice
she's one of eight million gen Z
first-time voters and she's clear about
what's at the top of her agenda they say
we have what I think eight years left
now to reduce our climate emissions by
1.5 degrees in order for this planet to
be livable so
the policies that are enacted now will
determine the fate of this planet for
centuries
he's not a dedicated Democrat
but she like many other young people
feels that when it comes to climate
change she has no other choice at the
end of the day if it's down to a
Democrat or Republican Democrats are far
more likely to either be persuaded or
actually make the right decision for the
climate
Aiden is also a student and a first-time
voter
he has two major issues in mind this
election cycle which makes choosing
between parties difficult I think
Democrats kind of have more of a
initiative and drive to
um you know tackle the the climate
change issues than conservatives but I
think economics wise I think
conservatives have a better
um
a better mindset going into that side of
the climate change issue hi excuse me
I'm part of a bipartisan he's involved
with left middle right
so the first question is how important
do you think your vote is in elections
that's a student-bounded news Outlet
showcasing diverse political
perspectives from gen z
um his work there means he talks with
many people his age I think there's a
lot of people like me who kind of don't
see a fit in either party so they're
kind of just stuck in the middle kind of
you know going back and forth between
left views and right views
Sandra Ochoa knows just how much young
voters can be more focused on policy
than party
she spent several months talking with
first-time voters for the non-partisan
Youth organizing group 18 by vote young
people aren't too tied down to parties
themselves so I think if other parties
were able to rise up to power and
represented us better I think young
people would be very willing to vote for
them because I don't think they're tied
down to a party name they're tied down
to the issues
first-time voters in the U.S have seen
the two-party system produce chaos and a
stalemate while real life issues they
care about become increasingly urgent
so young people will have to make
frustrating compromises with their votes
in this election
until the system or the parties adapt to
how these new voters think about
politics
then to dig a little deeper into youth
voting trends in the US we can now speak
to John Holtzman who's a global risk
consultant and a member of the Council
on Foreign Relations welcome to dwe John
um eight million members of gen Z are
eligible to vote in the U.S and they
could be a deciding factor if they turn
out to vote can you tell us will they
turn out
no um is the short answer but you're
right to go back a step in the last
election in 2020 youth voters
traditionally never show up this is
always the sacred cow of American kind
of thinking that if we could only the
Democrats can get the youth vote out
they'll win but last time they showed up
fully 50 of those 18 to 29 ended up
voting in 2020 and that was the margin
of Joe Biden's Victory because
traditionally the youth vote is about
two to one in favor of the Democrats
Biden has given them a lot on his plate
this time certainly the the end of Roe v
Wade and that returning to the States is
an issue that motivates a lot of younger
voters and frankly the bribe that was
getting rid of their student debt
whereas I had to pay it in in people not
in college have to pay it this was an
enticement to put it mildly to get them
out to vote but so far in the mail
balloting that's been looked at which is
very minor they're about it's only about
a third the total of male balloting what
it was was last time so that's back to
its normal really pathetic numbers and
that means the Democrats are likely to
have a very very long night tomorrow
now the political divide in the U.S has
you know rarely been deeper and our
young voters as polarized as their older
counterparts
um most of them know in the sense that
the overwhelming majority are are
Democrats I mean the way this works is
that various groups are overwhelmingly
one thing or the other and it isn't that
you try to get them to change in
aggregate you try to knock down those
numbers so for instance African
Americans voted 95 to 5 for Obama
Republicans don't need to win African
Americans they need to knock that number
down to about 75 25 and that's a huge
win for them likewise Hispanics have
voted two to one for Democrats the new
number is about 50 50 which is a huge
win for the Republicans so the key is to
knock down these overwhelming numbers so
younger voters still tend to vote
democratically it's about 60 percent as
opposed to 67. that means an awful lot
of young voters do vote Republican but
the majority vote Democratic Republicans
either want them not to turn out or to
vote Republican and knock down that
Advantage because they're going to win
strongly on older white college-educated
men
you've talked a little bit about what
you know people are motivated by I was
in the US last week I was speaking to a
25 year old who has voted Democrat in
the past but he said you know
um anything about these elections
doesn't really affect my paycheck so I
I'm just not gonna vote
um is that something that a lot of young
people would be able to relate to
absolutely and I think that's a shrewd
comment and you were right to listen to
him because the reality is the Democrats
bet that abortion would be the
overwhelming issue that somehow Donald
Trump who hasn't been in power for two
years would be the overwhelming issue
the issue is what it always is as James
Carville said Bill Clinton's famously
shrewd campaign manager it's almost
always the economy stupid and right now
with cost of living at 40-year highs
with inflation utterly out of control
with Biden having thrown gasoline onto
the fire by trillion dollar spending
plan after a trillion dollar spending
plan there's really nobody to blame but
him for inflation and critically
independent voters many youth by the way
are independent voters overwhelmingly
blame the president for inflation for
cost of living and for the recession to
come because the only way to get
inflation down is going to be as we've
seen with the FED to ratchet interest
rates up very quickly almost always
that's as Larry Summers pointed out that
leads to recession and young voters are
of course the most vulnerable segment of
society they're the ones actually doing
the jobs out there so this affects them
to pretend that pocketbook issues don't
motivate them is not to understand young
voters John holtzmann thank you so much
for your analysis really interesting
my pleasure thank you for having me